on a un job ou yom peu un excellent
agent vous savez nouveau local on ne
pouvait guillaume de bailly paul lefèvre
ou encore malotru trois identités trois
légendes pour un seul homme dans la
nouvelle saison du bureau des légendes
sur canal+ le héros imaginé par eric
rochant est plus que jamais au centre
d'une partie d'échecs entre la dgse et
la cia
ce qui me plaît dans le personnage c'est
ce côté le très professionnel du
militaire qui doit pas faire passer ses
émotions mais vous êtes très fort pour
que je suis vos émotions
il faut apprendre à encaisser les coups
ces notions sur votre pire ennemi
même si c'est son intérêt personnel qui
a mené tout le monde là dedans il est
reste quand même extrêmement
professionnelle et préfère passer
l'intérêt général avant siens c'est un
personnage qui en rédemption en
constante il a essayé de faire quelque
chose par amour et qui s'est mal passé
qui a pris une direction qui lui a
échappé et il essaye depuis de rattraper
ses erreurs de rattraper ses fautes je
crois en mon travail
et si j'ai fait des fautes que je ne
peux pas nettoyé il ya d'autres choses
que je peux faire proprement
il est dans une schizophrénie total
aider dans cette espèce de jonglage
permanent entre sauver une vie une vie
d'une personne qu'il aime et qui l'a mis
dans une situation terrible comme c'est
une grande histoire d'amour
on peut s'imaginer que malotru aille
très loin pour elle
vous pouvez plus arrêter guillaume si
vous arrêtez la cia d'ouvriers on peut
dire que malotru est un personnage
maudit plus qu'un bagage bonus un
bandage d'années il est d'années
essaient d'aller lui-même alors saison
il a fait une faute une erreur et il va
la payer de plus en plus fort
laval choir et j'ai choisi
j'ai choisi de sauver celle qui
souffrait par ma faute il faut qu'ils
réparent sa faute et c'est terrible
parce que en fait à vouloir réparer sa
faute c'est une fuite en avant
permanente pour faire en sorte qu' il
n'y ait pas de victime à cette première
faute est évidemment cette fuite en
avant permanente va multiplier les
victimes autour de lui j'ai toujours su
où j'en étais est ce que je devais faire
pour réparer ma faute mais j'ai réalisé
que cette faute était irréparable
retrouvez la nouvelle saison du bureau
de légende bientôt sur canal +